Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, je vais répondre
à la question de Nolan qui me demande :
« Que penses-tu de l'adoption d'enfants autochtones
par des familles non autochtones? »
Nolan, aujourd'hui on en parle beaucoup dans les médias, il y a eu une vague, le Sixties Scoop,
où les jeunes dans les années 60
se sont fait placer ou même adopter
par des familles sans le consentement,
ou même sans la connaissance, des familles
de ces enfants-là. Donc présentement,
il y a une grande question qui circule
dont le gouvernement canadien va devoir
répondre. Mais là, on parle d'adoption
aujourd'hui, dans le temps présent.
Je pense que, que ce soit une famille autochtone
ou une famille non autochtone, tant que
l'amour de l'enfant est là, c'est ce qui
compte le plus.
Cependant, c'est extrêmement important
de se rendre compte que si un jeune,
qui est visiblement autochtone,
vit une déconnexion ou vit un arrachement
à sa culture, ne pas y répondre
serait une erreur. Parce que ce sont
des problèmes qui vont ressortir, surtout
à l'adolescence ou même dans la vie adulte,
par rapport à se sentir déconnecté
de sa culture, de sa nation. Il y a beaucoup
de programmes présentement qui sont
instaurés dans les centres, comme des
centres d'adoption ou des centres de DPJ,
pour pouvoir aider les parents qui sont
non autochtone, qui n'ont aucune référence
autochtone à pouvoir connecter avec la
culture de l'enfant qu'ils adoptent et
à pouvoir aider le jeune à se sentir
connecté et justement à éviter tous
les troubles d'identité qui peuvent ressortir
plus tard quand on sent qu'on a été
arraché à une famille. Dans les cultures
des Premières Nations, souvent l'adoption,
l'adoption communautaire ou l'adoption
traditionnelle, est une pratique qui est très
très utilisée pour justement alléger
le fardeau familial et permettre
à l'enfant de bénéficier de l'amour
d'un parent, mais sans perdre le lien avec
le parent d'origine. Donc, ça facilite
énormément l'intégration dans
les familles d'adoption et ça permet aussi
d'élargir la famille d'origine.
Donc, tu renforces le lien
de communauté et tu renforce le lien
d'identité du jeune. Nolan, ta question
est excellente, il y a beaucoup
de témoignages qui existent de la part
de personnes qui ont vécu le Sixties Scoop
ou de jeunes qui sortent
du milieu de l'adoption.
N'hésitez pas à aller les lire,
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo
et surtout, n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
des questions à Espaces autochtones.
Je vous souhaite
une belle semaine!